on retrouve Véronique Michel C José le
groupe bonsoir
je vous remontre la courbe c'est c'est
vraiment très très clair comme chiffres
on est rendu à 10.000
249 québécois qui attendent chirurgie
depuis plus d'un an je précise depuis
plus d'un an parce que au total il y a
158 000 au Québec qui attendent
chirurgie mais bon
un délai normal c'est un délai normal
celui-là ne l'est pas ou dire de tous et
on vise 2500 Véronique on dit c'est de
l'argent dans une enveloppe qu'on a
trouvé parce que c'est des actes qu'on
faisait pas 400 millions on veut
encourager les infirmières ça prend des
salles d'opération ça prend
là il faut que ça fonctionne il y a
énormément de pression il y a de la
pression sur le gouvernement il y a de
la pression sur les médecins parce que
tous les jours je suis convaincu que les
députés reçoivent des courriels des
appels de gens qui disent et moi là je
dois me faire remplacer les hanches je
dois me faire remplacer les genoux ça
fait un an deux ans même que j'attends
je souffre le martyr je suis pas capable
de me tous les services au privé faites
quelque chose alors je suis convaincu
que des messages comme ça ils en ont
tous les jours et cette pression là elle
est de plus en plus forte maintenant que
effectivement la pandémie elle est
derrière nous Michel C donc pour
c'est une enveloppe de 400 millions qui
était déjà là je le répète et avec ça on
espère que le personnel va arriver parce
que les salles d'opération bon les
médecins eux vont travailler plus ils
sont prêts à travailler plus ils vont
faire plus d'argent mais ils sont prêts
à travailler plus mais il faut qu'il y a
des gens autour d'eux ils opèrent pas
seuls
et on veut tous que ça marche non on
veut tous que le système de santé soit
capable parce qu'on connaît tout le
monde des gens qui attendent après une
opération quoi que ce soit et qui
s'offre pendant ce temps mais les
soupçons énormes et
c'est pas la première fois qu'on nous
dit que ça va marcher alors vous me
permettrez de garder un peu de
scepticiste là-dedans j'espère que ça va
marcher mais le vrai problème dans cette
histoire-là c'est un pénurie de
personnel et ça même si on a de la plus
grosse enveloppe budgétaire qu'on veut
ça réglera pas ça José
oui en effet et sur internet le
président de la Fédération des médecins
spécialiste du Québec dire que c'est le
problème c'est pas seulement les
chirurgies qui attendent depuis plus
d'un an il y a même des chirurgies en
ontologie qui attendent juste trop
longtemps point à la ligne et donc qui
mettent carrément des vies en danger
c'est sûr que de voir que les
infirmières n'ont pas été appelés à
participer à la préparation ça
criera pas une atmosphère de travail ça
ça m'inquiète un peu là on a vu un petit
peu les complaintes la fée là-dessus
et aussi il y a un autre problème au
Québec dont on dont on parle peu mais on
a aussi ces médecins je pense que vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure un peu
Patrice c'est qu'il y a ces médecins
aussi c'est chirurgien qui se promènent
du public au privé et il y a aussi les
médecins qui encouragent leur patients
en leur disant
si vous restez avec moi vous attendez au
public ça va prendre un an deux ans
trois ans mais allez donc au privé
privée si vous avez des grosses
assurances ou si vous avez les moyens et
là il y a cette machine là infernale
aussi qui se nourrit depuis des années
de ça alors et je vois pas on entend pas
non plus une volonté de mettre fin à ça
donc oui comme le dit Michel C on se le
souhaite que ça fonctionne ça va sans
dire mais il y a des obstacles quand
même ils sont qui sont devant le
ministre à ça docteur Oliver répondu que
lui eux ces membres souhaitaient opérer
au public davantage mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a des chirurgiens orthopédiques
qui eux ont des salles plein
d'infirmières de personnel prêtent les
fins de semaine ils disent à telle
personne ben viens sur une prochaine je
peux t'opérer pour 30 40 50 000 dollars
bon ensuite alors à suivre un petit tour
de table rapide sur le reste de la
réforme parce que Monsieur Dubé vu que
les médecins spécialistes Véronique en
face plus
fasse plus de garde soit plus à
l'hôpital soit plus conscients qui sont
dans une communauté de soins enfin bref
est-ce que là ça s'avance après vous
moi je doute qu'on puisse adopter la
réforme en juin vraiment là j'ai des
gros gros
disant que si ça se fait d'ici la fin de
l'année mais peut-être que ça du bien
aura gagné son pari là mais d'ici juin à
entendre les groupes en commission
parlementaires
au début lorsqu'il avait fait l'annonce
sa réforme on sentait que tout le monde
voulait participer tout le monde voulait
mettre l'épaule à la roue plat à la
lecture des 1180 articles on dit que là
le diable se trouve dans les détails ben
là les différents groupes se disent
ouais finalement j'ai pas sûr de cet
article là puis on sent que la pluie
qu'il avait perdu au moment de son
annonce c'est un petit peu effrité et
c'est comme s'il doit les convaincre du
bienfait de sa réforme Puiseux de leur
côté doit convaincre le ministre de les
écouter davantage les faire participer
davantage surtout dans la prise de
décision alors je ne doute pas que ça va
avancer comme projet de loi d'ici juin
mais je doute que ça va être adopté
avant cet été ce qui serait pas une
bonne nouvelle José pour Monsieur Dubé
qui mesure
l'étendue de la tâche la Poste pandémie
non c'est très intéressant ce que dit
Véronique qui est un peu là j'ai un peu
la même impression
mais écoutez le ministre déposé un
projet de loi mammouth mammouth ça se
mange une bouchée à la fois mais ça fait
beaucoup de boucher donc ça fait ça
prend énormément de temps il y a aussi
des groupes qui ont été exclus ou non
invité à la commission parlementaire
comme les médecins québécois pour régime
public par exemple et là il y a des
parties d'opposition qui demandent
est-ce qu'ils soient entendus donc il y
a d'autres groupes qui devraient
normalement aussi être entendu donc
c'est fort possible comme vous le dites
pour le gouvernement le goût même s'il
est encore au début de son mandat ça
reste son deuxième mandat ça reste un
début de deuxième mandat qui va pas très
bien qui va
à plusieurs dossiers la santé c'est
central et s'il veut retourner en
élection évidemment en 2026 il va
falloir qu'il y ait eu des améliorations
notables parce que je pense que la
patience des Québécois est vraiment à
bout là face à ce système là donc ça a
l'air de rien mais si ça passe pas en
juin s'est mis à l'automne ça va le
temps va commencer à courir Michel un
petit mot là-dessus la machine
législative fonctionne à un rythme qui
est le sien et puis ça permettra pas de
faire ça un jeu c'est pas possible
surtout on s'en va pas 24 juin on ajoute
un deuxième semaine de juin alors quand
on a passé la loi 101 l'Assemblée
nationale assez j'ai tout l'été et elle
a été adoptée à la fin alors c'est pas
la seule loi qui a pensé comme ça et
Véronique
mais mais
important chaque fois que un nouveau
groupe qui arrive qui dit ouais il y a
cet article là ça va pas pour nous il y
a un problème avec ça c'est un peu
normal dans un projet de loi de cette
grosseur là je trouve que pour le
ministre c'est la barre de plus alors
que s'il peut faire passer ça au mois de
juin je pense qu'on va il y a une
canadien professionnel
on a pas eu Bédard c'est ça
hausse de 30000 de dollars du salaire
des députés donc la CAQ et les libéraux
sont d'accord avec la recommandation de
ce comité
multi-partie d'Aix députés qui avait dit
il faut un rattrapage à l'arrière on va
voir le tableau c'est grosso modo c'est
30000 dollars pour le salaire de base et
député ainsi de suite ministre Premier
ministre
Michel seoget ça va pas bon ça va passer
parce qu'ils sont majoritaires est-ce
que ça va bien passer d'après vous dans
l'opinion publique
qui se donne la peine de l'expliquer
comme il faut je pense ça va bien passer
regardez des comparables dans société
québécoise un directeur d'école ça fait
un petit peu moins que ça que 130 000
dollars c'est important le directeur
d'école mais depuis tout aussi un
professeur de cégep en milieu de
carrière fait plus qu'un député avec le
nouveau le nouveau barème et c'était
vrai etc alors à un moment donné on peut
faire des choses mais tout le monde ici
on connaît des députés on sait qu'on
vient faire le travail on sait des
heures que ça prend surtout ceux qui
sont en région qui devraient être
compensés pour ça d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils sont en route tellement souvent
alors moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça
je croyais mais je payais moins cher que
le pire joueur de la Ligue nationale je
vais appeler il y a des gens qui
soulignaient qui a des conseillers
politiques qui sont payés davantage bon
n'empêche José Legault il y a des gens
qui sont contre on faisait un des bases
cette semaine ça enfin sur les équipes
allait même aller dire il faut baisser
même le salaire pour être plus près du
salaire média québécois est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va passer José dans
l'opinion publique
je dirais que probablement que oui et
parce que je pense que quand même une
bonne partie de la population est
consciente que c'est pas un travail
comme un autre on répète pas là tout ce
qui était dit oui les heures de fou et
cetera mais il reste aussi que ce sont
les représentants du peuple et au Québec
c'est pas que les députés font pitié
c'est pas qu'ils sont c'est pas qu'ils
ont une maigre pitance mais hier
attrapage à faire là par contre ou il
pourrait y avoir un peu de Donald donna
si je puis dire ce serait de regarder
aussi comme la juge le rugby l'avait
fait le fond de passion c'est quand même
un régime extrêmement généreux parce que
il y a eu ça pour justement équilibrer
avec le fait que les députés du Québec
qui était peut-être moins payé
qu'ailleurs etc c'est aussi parfois
difficile de se replacer une fois que on
a plus son siège etc mais si on augmente
et qu'on garde le gros fond de passion
aussi en même temps ça ça peut ça peut
rendre la pilule plus difficile à avaler
Véronique là-dessus est-ce qu'on peut
sortir
c'est cette prise de décision future de
la main des parlementaires parce qu'ils
sont forcément jugés partis
là une fois là il y a rattrapage qui
serait fait est-ce que après on peut
sortir avec un comité d'experts est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un processus qui soit
moins moins près des députés du vote des
députés va falloir qu'ils trouvent une
façon de le faire ça c'est clair et net
pour trouver le mécanisme ils vont
devoir voter au moins une fois sur le
mécanisme en question pour que dans le
futur ça puisse se faire automatiquement
de façon indépendante tout ça il y aura
jamais de bons moments pour voter une
augmentation de salaire des députés ça
s'est discuté plein de fois dans le
passé à chaque fois on se disait ah oui
mais non on est en négociation avec les
employés d'État ah non c'est l'austérité
parce que le gouvernement aussi à
essayer de le faire alors il y en a six
attentes il y en aura jamais de bons
moments alors pourquoi pensez-vous
qu'ils font maintenant alors qu'on est
encore en début de mandat que c'est un
gouvernement qui est très populaire ça
c'est déposé à la toute fin de la
session pour en débattre le moins
longtemps possible si avant l'été pour
qu'on retourne en septembre les gens
n'en parlent plus donc c'est comme si
tout était mis en place pour que ça se
fasse le plus discrètement possible mais
en même temps moi ça fait 10 ans que je
travaille ici au Parlement puis je dois
admettre une chose le travail c'est
énormément accéléré parce que la vie
s'est accélérée alors vraiment là c'est
une cadence qui est il y a une
méconnaissance je pense des gens de la
cadence à laquelle est confrontée les
députés en ce moment dans leur travail
il faut aussi que l'emploi soit actif
auprès de gens qui dans la société par
ailleurs sont appelés à gagner beaucoup
plus bon ok alors très bien premier
résultat
tu es très bien trop minutieux 15
on s'est parti un peu en fous ce matin
je fais entendre
Eric Duhem
qui flirt les histoires qui peuvent qui
peuvent faire jaser entre que celle-là a
fait jaser il a même sa même forcer le
ministre de l'éducation à en parler et
ensuite quelqu'un qui vient dire un
député justement respirant peut-être par
le nez on écoute tout seul
c'est absolument aberrant que on soit
rendu à dire qu'il faut abolir la fête
des mères ou la fête des pères parce que
certains enfants leur mère sera disparus
parce qu'il y a des peuples familles
monoparentales je dis ça a toujours
existé puis la fête des mères a toujours
existé nous ce qu'on voit derrière ça
c'est clairement l'entrée du hockisme
qui s'infiltre dans nos écoles
moelleux
de remplacer la fête des mères ou la
fête des pères par la fête des parents
je suis pas d'accord avec ça là
s'ajuster à des besoins particuliers
dans certaines classes c'est normal
c'est toujours l'élève
ultimement c'est à l'élève que tu dois
penser mais d'arriver puis de dire la
politique dans mon centre de service
dorénavant c'est qu'il y aura plus de
faire des maires il aurait pu te faire
des pairs parce qu'on va remplacer ça
par une fête des parents ça je trouve
que c'est une mauvaise idée
en fait vérification faite c'était une
école
près de Québec
Véronique deux enseignantes qui
peut-être sont maladroitement prises en
envoyant la note aux parents disant on
va remplacer mais c'était pour pour
c'était pour ne pas mettre dans une
situation délicate des enfants qui
avaient pas de parabole bref je résume
et là c'est parti un peu en vrai
n'est-ce pas Véronique
veut avoir de la visibilité on le vu
dans les dernières semaines c'est une
façon d'aller en chercher deux moi je me
demande pourquoi le gouvernement répond
et alimente la controverse pourquoi il
s'assi c'est pour répondre si c'est
est-ce que c'est une tendance on dirait
pas alors pourquoi répondre on me dit
ouais parce que si on répond pas on va
se faire reprocher de pas répondre
troisièmement
Eric Duhem associe ça au walkisme c'est
péjoratif le gouvernement ne veut
absolument pas être associé au walkisme
d'autant plus qu'il
Québec soldat comme étant des woks alors
ça mélange de tout ça rapidement désolé
vraiment difficile c'est une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle de la part
des rituels mais voyons donc c'était des
parents de bonne foi des gens de bonne
foi c'est pas c'est rien à voir avec le
wokis mais cette espèce de bientôt on va
nous sortir que cancer c'est la faute
aussi le ça ça plus aucun sens on est
dans l'absurde des Véronique tout à fait
raison on soupçonne Bernard daimé de
vouloir faire de la micro-gestion avec
sa réforme scolaire
conclusion rapidement
monsieur dum essaie d'importer au Québec
les guerres culturelles des États-Unis
on va entrer en toute la campagne
électorale américaine l'année prochaine
mais on devrait pas jouer dans ce film
là et lui a pas d'affaires à jouer moi
contre les waouh c'est pas utile c'est
pas lui décider comme les écoles vont
gérer ça très bien merci beaucoup à vous
trois à très bientôt au revoir bonne
soirée
bonne soirée au revoir